[Music]
darkness is the cannabis of the light is
my brush with light painting you can
create new worlds in the darkness my
name is Hana gusto mo and I paint with
life i live in Freeland we have amazing
nature here we have a long summer nights
that are warm and full of light but on
the opposite there is also this dark
part it's called polar night it starts
in December and it lasts for about 50
day the Sun doesn't rise above the
horizon at all and for life painter that
is quite cute I do long exposure
photography which is a photographic
technique that allows me to throw with
light the exposure times can vary from a
second two hours and the idea is to use
the light sources as the process or
pencils and the dark surroundings are
the canvas when i start i might do some
sketches on paper after that i go to the
location I search for details that i
want to emphasize
with some light treatment it will start
to look like a completely a new place
going through our dark roots or the
abandoned house you first think that all
I don't want to go there because there's
just so nasty looking dark places but to
life painting I have examined this
places and they look beautiful if you
the place differently
[Music]